in California cruise ship passengers
stranded by the coronavirus are being
screened after their ship docked in
Oakland about 1200 passengers roughly
half of the 2400 passengers who were on
board the Grand Princess still have not
set foot on land one couple has now
filed a lawsuit arguing the cruise line
put their health at risk Carter Evans is
at the port in Oakland Carter how long
will it take to get those people off
that ship
well because everyone has to be screened
it could take two to three days to
complete the process now as you can
imagine passengers aboard the ship are
pretty excited to leave this cruise but
their long journey home is just
beginning the first stop for passengers
leaving the Grand Princess is this
secure 11 acre containment area the most
critically ill are loaded into
ambulances most are taking buses or
chartered flights to u.s. military bases
with foreign nationals headed to the
airport for flights out of the country
passengers wearing protective masks were
interviewed by crew members Monday after
they were allowed to leave their rooms
for the first time in day 19 crew
members and two passengers on the cruise
have tested positive for corona virus
the ship has also been linked to 12
cases from a previous trip including one
death my condition is not the best I
have a pacemaker deleted in my chest Ron
Weiss Berger and his wife Eva are suing
the Cruise Lines parent company saying
the cruise continue to sail knowing that
some passengers and crew had already
been exposed to kovat 19 if we would
have known let's say before we learned
about in the first port we would have
gotten off that ship and flown back home
despite the recent outbreaks at sea at
least six four cruise ships set sail
Monday but the 53 billion dollar a year
industry could be impacted by the State
Department's warning to Americans not to
take cruises I want to let others know
what we are getting into once they sign
up will
well after everyone's been screened the
entire site here is going to be pressure
washed with a bleach solution to
decontaminate it as for the lawsuit
Princess Cruises says it doesn't respond
to pending litigations instead right now
it's focusing on the passengers and crew
Tony Carter thank you